this is from The Daily Mail judge asks
Trump lawyer if president would be
immune from prosecution for using Seal
Team 6 to assassinate a political rival
in explosive courtroom Showdown this is
a really really great story and it's a
very important story for all of you this
is an excellent way to help people
understand that these issues in law are
nuanced and the headline does not
accurately portray what is being uh uh
the information being conveyed first let
me start by Shocking All of You by
saying it is a fact and it is true in
this argument it makes absolute sense
and it is reasonable and rational to
argue if the president ordered the
assassination of his political rival you
could not prosecute him unless he has
been impeached and convicted already
that's the statement the judges tried to
make it seem like it was some egregious
and shocking thing that such an argument
would be made but it does make sense
because there actually is an official AR
an argument for an official course of
action in which a president or
politician would assassinate their rival
I'll give you a simple
explanation president a learns through
the Senate intelligence committee or or
the house intelligence committee or
whatever Foreign Affairs top secret
information that a political rival of
his has been making deals with a foreign
adversary and is going to be meeting
with them in a foreign country to
deliver top secret nuclear code
information from the United States
Unfortunately they discovered this much
too late and they need to put a stop to
it the president goes to a federal judge
who reviews the evidence the arguments
are made and a warrant is issued the
president then orders this man must be
stopped by any means necessary after
this political rival is caught in the
act of selling State Secrets an act of
treason when US forces try to apprehend
and arrest him he resists and draws a
weapon and is killed by the president's
forces the assassination of a political
rival now perhaps you can argue that
they mean like just taking him out in
that instance as I described it there
would be no impeachment Congress would
say no we were the ones that delivered
the intelligence that this man had
betrayed his country and a judge signed
off on the warrant for his for his
apprehension and or execution for
treason in which case you could not
prosecute the president for taking this
action as no one in Congress would
believe a crime had been committed now
if
Donald Trump or any president just
straight up killed their political rival
for political power instantly in
Congress they would be impeached and
convicted and then they could be
criminally charged the important thing
to understand here is that were this to
not be the case as Democrats are arguing
this could mean that states or elements
of the federal government could
criminally charge a president whenever
they feel like it before before during
or after they're even in office if they
feel threatened by him and the founding
fathers were concerned this would
disrupt the political process a man
announces he's going to run for office
so what happens a rival political actor
in government decides I'll criminally
charge him so that he can't win and
that's exactly where we are yeah no um
it's interesting right because it it's
really a question of process as you
mentioned so saying something like he
would have to be impeached first is like
saying he would have to be arrested
first it's just part of the process it
doesn't mean it's something he's allowed
to do it means that we actually have a
process laid out for how that's taken
care of this this seems like there is a
process here uh Trump's lawyers have
made a completely sound argument that I
believe is correct you can't accuse a
president of committing crime so in in
this instance we're talking about Trump
investigating voter fraud it's actually
the duty of the the executive branch to
investigate voter fraud should there be
any but because there's a conflict of
interest in that it was Trump's election
they're arguing it was a criminal
activity well I believe it is correct
Trump should be uh there should be an
investigation as a conflict of interest
the determination was uh he was
impeached and then he was acquitted How
Could You criminally charge someone
who's been acquitted for this very thing
they're going after him why the
arguments to the Supreme Court are the
point of the Democrat process create oh
so they're in a federal a federal
appeals court right now and making these
arguments on immunity and the Supreme
Court I is going to hear Trump's case on
the ballot uh issue but right now if
these judges come out and say the
president is not immune then we are
inching towards absolute dictator ship
and the collapse of the
Republic oh boy yeah that's a pretty
great takedown um great analysis right
there because you're right there is a
process there is a procedure that we
have to go through I mean the he has to
be impeached he has to be convicted uh
in the Senate that hasn't happened here
and um there is that is the argument
exactly that attorneys are making is
they have a presidential immunity that
it is there for the reasons that you've
cited this this case they're bringing
against them is is the offense it it the
offense is not to criminally charge
Trump that's a byproduct the offensive
attack against our Republic is this for
the judges to rule presidents can be
criminally charged then the next time an
America first cand let's say let's say
in eight years vras Swami is is the
front runner what will happen federal
agents to prevent him from winning will
file criminal charges against him let's
say he actually gets elected let's say
let's say there's a back room deal and
he goes to the establishment and says
look there's a few things that I want to
do for this country country but I agree
to play ball with you on terms on
foreign policy they say okay then he
gets elected and says no I'm going to
play things my way they go okay you're
under arrest we're going to criminally
charge you now it doesn't matter who you
are if you're the president or not it
doesn't matter if the people want you
elected if the Democrats win the ability
to criminally charge the sitting
president no election will ever matter
ever
again yeah I mean I think that that does
make sense and I'm not I mean I don't
have a whole lot of faith in in most of
the judges and and judicial system that
is trying Trump I think that most of
these uh most of these cases should have
been thrown out um I think the one in uh
about the what was it actually no I'm
not I I think they maybe maybe Georgia
has something but either way um so I
don't have any faith that they're going
to that that the judge will decide you
know in a in a fair way if you listen to
these judges you would come to the
conclusion they will not judge in a fair
way I mean so so I mean as much as again
this is this goes back to my point why
so why I'm so blackpilled I don't think
that the justice system is treating any
of this fairly and it and the people
that are that are Prosecuting tend to be
Democrats you know the the opposing
party the it just doesn't I don't see
how this is in any way Fair how why the
American people aren aren't saying look
this is clearly political and and making
more noise about this well yeah I mean
why would we expect a fair outcome when
none of this is fair to begin with the
fact that he's even gone to trial Donald
Trump has been more investigated and
he's been more um he's had more charges
brought up against him than any
president in recent history and are you
going to sit here with a straight face
and tell me he's been the most corrupt
that's ridiculous more corrupt than
George Bush more corrupt than Bill
Clinton more corrupt than uh Barack
Obama it's complet War we we are
absolutely watching the erosion of the
of the Republic we we are did you guys
see uh uh was it a couple days ago that
senator from New Hampshire said quote a
democracy if you can keep it embarassing
embarrassing intentionally erasing
history why here's here's what I try to
explain to people democracy does not
mean rule by majority they think it does
democracy means rule by the absolute
slimmest of minorities what people think
a democracy will be 10 people ask what's
for lunch and everyone votes people
think democracy means six people say we
want pepperoni pizza congratulations you
got pepperoni pizza I'll tell you what
democracy is at Occupy Wall Street they
needed a way to keep supplies dry so
they used to have these things called
General assemblies where the whole group
of occupy gets together and then they'll
you know petition everybody and then
raise their hands and wiggle their
fingers if they like things the idea was
hey we had a bunch of clothes and
supplies that are getting wet from the
rain we need plastic bins to store them
so if it rains or snows they will not be
destroyed simple right well you'd think
in a democracy the average person
assumes you're going to get a yes or no
vote right that's not what happened what
happened was everybody said all in favor
of buying the bins the NOS have it why
well plastic is bad for the environment
so we can't have plastic okay well
what's the solution there's no other
material you're not going to get a glass
one you're not going to get a w a wooden
sealed basket with rubber or anything
right well how about this how about we
get recycled reused bins so that way
we're not contributing okay now we've
got a proposal here all in favor of
recycled plastic bins the NOS have it
why because was this sourced fair trade
were the workers treated properly I'm
not kidding this happened eventually
what happens is in a
democracy there is only a tiny
percentage that actually wants the
outcome and the majority of people
compromise with each other to create
some wacky outcome that makes no sense
the end result Was the vote that won was
recycled fair trade plastic bins that
are bought off of Craigslist and you
can't spend more than x amount so
happened well that's clearly impossible
so the people who had access to the
money just went to I went I believe they
went to a super like a department store
and just bought standard plastic bins
for 20 bucks and then brought them in
there and then just said sure we did
what you we wanted if everybody gets a
vote on how to run something you don't
get a simple majority you get this weird
amalgamation of the of the desires of as
many people as possible and then the
result is how many people came out and
filled up a form saying I want this
specific kind of plastic bin three out
of 100 and that's who wins in the end
that's direct democracy well so this is
actually something a good friend of mine
pointed out he said like have you ever
tried to make dinner plans with multiple
people hell it's like it's it's really
difficult but you know what works out
really well when like you're a kid and
you're in the car with your parents and
your dad's like here's where we're going
for dinner and then you just go there
and you pick what you want off the menu
right but but were these things always
always end up is one person just making
the decision anyway so we're kind of
fooling ourselves if we think we really
have this process where everyone's
actually coming together and getting
what they dude I got an idea we should
totally do this so freed dastan um our
new studio is done the I should say the
new structure the buildings past
inspection it is it is done all we're
doing now is the main the actual
technical buildout for the studio and
then we'll be there in a few weeks we
let's make a
video where we give everyone 10 options
for dinner
dessert oh let's just do this let's just
let's just do uh uh dinner we'll say
here's a list of meats here's a list of
carbs here's a list of vegetables vote
for which one you like the
most do you think you're going to get a
delicious eggplant Parmesan with fresh
ricotta on top no you're going to get
like a beef steak with a scoop of
vanilla ice cream espresso poured around
it some asparagus stock sticking out of
it and you're going to be like I am not
eating this but hey that's what everyone
voted for M most people wanted beef most
people wanted ice cream most people
wanted asparagus most people wanted
espresso and then you're going to be
like welcome to democracy yeah it's it
it's and it's been referred to as the
Tyranny tyranny of the minority right uh
under that scenario and that's there's
been a concerted effort for decades now
to take control of that word and to
foist it up democracy let's save our
democracy I mean I get so sick and tired
of seeing this too we're seeing
democracy 2024 that's not what our
country is we're con tional Republic
their country it that's right and and
I've heard you say this before where
words really have meaning and Democrats
in the left are so good at co-opting
that and just putting that out there
time and again when they when they say
our democracy they're not including you
no that's right they really mean our
yeah it's like the way the way I've
described it is three guys break into
your house start destroying your living
room and when you walk in and say get
out of my house one burglar looks at the
other burglar and says he's trying to
kick us out of
house yeah he's not calling it your
house he's not acting like you're a part
of his his plans MH yeah no it's
absolutely right it's it's always so
funny to me because for years and years
what the left did and what they did
within the popular culture is they made
people laugh at these American buzzwords
right so they said oh come on
conservatives and right wiers talk about
freedom and freedom just the word became
a punchline oh it's Freedom oh it's
America uh and of course you say it in a
Southern accent because that's that's
Peak comedy um
and now they'll go our democracy this is
about our democracy which is hilarious
they're just they're like throwing
around these like dim store patriotic
terms without actually thinking about
the ideas they're expressing what do you
mean by that like why is this good for
democracy why is it good for democracy
to remove the front runner of the
Republican primaries out of the process
because they're saying our democracy
they're not saying democracy they're our
democracy agree that's my point they're
just throwing this around as a buzz word
no no no no no the elite know what
they're doing I'm arguing with you on
this I'm saying you are incorrect I'm
saying that I I don't know how much we
disagree because the elite are using it
that way but I think your average person
who hears that and throws that around or
thinks it sounds good doesn't detect it
my point is it they're saying the fact
that Donald Trump could win is a threat
to our plan that's what the Press is
saying so there's uh a couple people
that are running for the Democratic
primary and I forget the guy's name or
whatever but he tweeted out me and
Marion Williamson are not insurrection
cists why are they blocking our primary
and I said because you running in an
election is a threat to their power
structure the quote unquote democracy
they have is not a democracy of the
people it's a de democratic system of
the elites where they get to decide and
if you actually ran against them you
would threaten their power structure
absolutely I I'm not talking about that
I agree with you that they have a kind
of oligarchy and they're trying to
preserve their power but when the reason
they seize on to these words like
democracy is because they know your
average person who doesn't have time to
research or think about these things
hears that and goes like Oh democracy
that's a good word this is about
democracy yeah I I I think to a certain
degree but my point is that they're
literally saying we are trying to build
a new communist system yep that we we
would call like like North Korea calls
their country the Democratic Republic of
North Korea yeah good point People's
Republic of China so they're saying our
democracy is they may all be saying our
Communist dictatorship they're saying
they're saying this election Communist
dictatorship is on the ballot they call
it democracy mhm yeah cuz that's a nice
word he used good word I like when he
uses good word when he used good word
he's right right this goes this goes
back you're against goodward this goes
back yes I am against goodward um this
goes back to uh this goes back to to the
the point about maoism because that was
something that Mao said like communism
is the idea of Communism is pure
democracy he's not entirely wrong you
know and and it it will
destroy the Republic which is the intent
you know the and there's as it's
frustrating when you talk to people that
get their news from John Stewart or from
Comedy Central and they believe all of
the the the messages that are coming out
of Comedy Central and that's that's
really one of the most damaging things
that that's happened to the to the US
has been the ability of of The Daily
Show to just feed people the most insane
propaganda and have the most ridiculous
framing of anything conservative and
it's really been toxic because it's it's
affected the way that PE like you were
saying about freedom and stuff the way
that people
perceive things that are fundamental to
the United States and the left really
does has gotten to the point where they
hate America they hate liberalism you
talk to any leftist and they they don't
call themselves Liber liberals they call
themselves progressives I like Jimmy
Kimmel W this really long rant about
Aaron Rogers and it was the stupidest
thing ever because he was like calling
someone a pedo isn't an opinion and he
threatened to Sue Aaron Rogers but then
he goes on to say he read about the
Dunning Krueger effect where people are
too stupid to realize they're stupid he
said ignorant but I love this because uh
he should have talked to his lawyer
because publicly stating that you
believe the person who defamed you is
too stupid to realize they defamed you
is an affirmative defense for the person
who defamed you under times V Sullivan
in which case if he ever did Sue Aaron
Rogers could say Jimmy Kimmel admitted
it I genuinely believed what I had said
and you know what that's it case is
missed you know um Jimmy Kimmel also
made a dig at him for going to Community
College which is hysterical how many of
these leftists complain about how
expensive college is and about how
horrible the student deck crisis is only
to turn around and laugh at people who
took responsibility and said I'm going
to go somewhere less expensive you're
going to go somewhere where I won't rack
up a lot of debt none of them believe
any of the things they're saying all
about status it's all about hierarchy
it's all about kissing their own I want
to point out Aaron Rogers never said
Jimmy Kimmel was on the list he said
Jimmy Kimmel is probably worried the
list may come out and the interpretation
by most people was that he was implying
Kimmel was on the list maybe or I stated
this before the abstein documents were
released and there's more coming out
every day uh Jimmy Kimmel came out and
said I've never met with Epstein I never
flown his plane well Aaron Rogers didn't
say that but I actually think there's a
very good reason that Jimmy Kimmel is
sweating bullets over these documents
and that is it has been reported that he
was in business with what's the guy's
name Andrew Perry Lang he was in
business with Epstein's personal chef
who owned a restaurant I think it was
called APL Jimmy Kimmel was good friends
with him Jimmy Kimmel may be worried
about the release of this not because
he's on the list he could be
peripherally mentioned but because his
good friend is on the list so Aaron
Rogers said a very basic statement which
probably is true Jimmy Kimmel has reason
to be worried and and it's not just uh
Perry Lang it's many people in Hollywood
who may appear on these lists who are
friends with jimmmy Kimmel so if those
lists come out and it turns out that a
good friend of Jimmy Kimmel was deeply
involved and was going on with Epstein
and it's true this guy was Epstein's
personal chef Jimmy Kimmel may be
worried that could damage his brand or
his net worth or something even though
he's not accused of being a pedo thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time